the folks at you okay it's not exactly
the same but it's pretty close to just a
standard parabola right so a parabola
has the equation f of X is equal to X
square so how could I take this idea
here
and what would it mean if this was the
particular function you'd say look the
gradient which is not just a number it's
a function that's changing
it's equal to do this thing as H gets
really really really really real time so
instead of FCR I can actually put in
well this is what it is okay
so sort of f of X plus h I'd say X plus
h or swear you see I'm putting X plus h
into my function okay minus f of X which
is just x squared
there's my rise that doesn't look very
helpful okay so can I do anything just
to make it simpler well oh yeah I write
what do you expand this thing out what
do you get
I've got next witness then I've got
twice the country to things and sweat
okay
there's the first part in the number
next women here all business about my
age now you can see I've got some
cancellation happening right this time
and this gonna cancel which would leave
me with 2x H and H squared okay but this
point I've got a common factor
everything's gonna mention it okay so
I'm going to divide through
okay now you look at this because I've
gotten rid of my fraction okay I can
actually do some lunch because it's a
below as H approaches zero
what does 2x plus h approach what does
it actually become well then H just
vanishes off it just disappears right so
I can actually saw accessory and thank
you for zero I couldn't do it before so
now that's just equal to 2x the H is
become insignificant
and what this is me listen about what
statements can we make on the basis of
this this is totally it's not gradient
right what used to say the grading of
this line is 1 for 3/4 minus 1 but now
the gradient has an accident function
it's changing what is his name let's
think about what extra actually looks
like
I don't wanna get you guys to draw a
with me just don't really really small
table okay which has x squared function
X and 2x okay so this course wants to
think about it anybody let's take one
let's say six sure this is okay so when
X is equal six
what's f of X is 36 okay that's quite
high up what's F dash X this gradient
function you know okay well it'll be 2
times 6 which is 12
what does that mean what's a great into
12 that's super state right which is
exactly what you expect every here when
X is 6 okay let's pick it up as quick of
a heard like say 0 okay when x equals 0
I'm at the origin 2 X is also equal to 0
what does that mean what does a line the
great Azur look like it's this a
horizontal line which is exactly what
you see here if i zoom D defective if I
take your fuchsia okay but that's what
they're sure not actually even this box
it looks like the horizontal line always
doesn't positive zero let's take a
number every other side say minus 3
what's the function equal to is equal to
9 that's terrible what's 2 times X the
create function it's minus 6 what does
that mean it means when a gradient is
they if I'm decreasing which is exactly
what you expect okay so this idea right
and with a simple example it's so
crucial and it saw it forms the basis of
everything else that we're going to look
at in this topic right which this is
where we start where they call this
first
okay it's a way to but just from the
basic definition of what he's dreamed
okay and therefore how can I find the
gradient function if great advice
everyone that's what this is okay
now I'm taking it with you've got a very
very instant issue small gap between the
points that are wise anyway okay